filled by China as a journey of
friendship cooperation and peace the two
dear friends as they described
themselves wrapped up a state visit with
a warm goodbye and talk of Russia and
China being the driving forces behind
changes not seen in 100 years
Russia's interpretation of the visit
summed up in one headline reading guest
from heaven in Ukraine where Russia
wages its brutal War a hellish morning
two nine-story residential buildings
were hidden a strike in the city of
zaparizia at least 30 people were
injured and one person killed it was
captured on surveillance video 13 months
on Ukraine's president took to social
media writing these strikes should not
become just an ordinary day in Ukraine
the United States had urged Chinese
president XI Jin to persuade Russia to
quote halt the war crimes China's
foreign Ministry spokesperson pushed
back today
asking is it fair to push the conflict
towards escalation with spillover
effects on the worlds the state visit
did not result in any peace deal
developments the two did sign bilateral
trade deals cementing future
cooperations and sectors such as
Agriculture and Technology Far From Any
pomp or ceremony Ukrainian President
Vladimir zielinski spent Wednesday
touring the Donetsk region surprise
soldiers at a gas station snapped photos
the president spent time shaking hands
and handing out medals in a hospital and
at a location identified only as being
in the direction of buckmut an Eastern
hotbed of deadly fighting the visit no
doubt Ukraine's way of showing the world
its troops are holding steady Crystal
commencing Global News London